good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
3076 object class
uid special containment procedures SC p
3076 is to be contained in a dedicated
Aviary at site 104 it is to be fed twice
daily and provided new forms of simple
entertainment monthly visual contact
with SCP 376 is to be limited to an
absolute minimum outside of testing no
Personnel are allowed entry to the
containment chamber test subjects must
be confined to a cell or containment
chamber to prevent the possible spread
of infection it is recommended that test
subjects in the tertiary state agage of
SCP 3076a be terminated and all related
materials destroyed any contact between
SCP 376 and computer systems is strictly
prohibited description SCP 376 is an
albino black build Magpie pah hudsonia
it is abnormally intelligent expressing
an understanding of written language
though it is unable to understand most
verbal communication it is estimated
that SCP 3076 has the mental capacity of
a 10-year-old human being SCP 3076 is
capable of deceptive Behavior such as
feigning illness or ignorance and
possesses extremely long-term recall SCP
376 may use these skills in attempts to
escape containment unless properly cared
for when directly viewing SCP 376 all
Sapient beings analytical systems will
feel a compulsion to produce some type
of artistic expression this is the first
stage of the SCP 3076 cognitive
infection SCP
3076a those with a pre-existing
disposition toward one form or medium
will feel compelled to more strongly
pursue these prior Tendencies those with
no previous experience with artistic
expression appear to select a random art
form to pursue SCP 376 is only able to
produce this effect after several
aggregated hours of viewing though the
precise number varies from subject to
subject it is also possible to transfer
the effect through other sensory means
especially if the subject is blind
though the time required for infection
to occur is much higher note that this
stage of infection is reversible if
contact between SCP 3076 and the subject
is terminated to date no subjects have
expressed satisfaction with their work
and will continue to produce art in an
attempt to improve after approximately 2
weeks SCP 376a enters its secondary
stage and no action short of induced
coma will reverse the effect subjects in
this stage of infection will improve at
a normal rate considering heightened
resolve and enthusiasm over time
subjects will continue to devote more
and more time to the pursuit of their
art form without outside intervention
about 80% of subjects expire due to
thirst or starvation as most effect Ed
individuals forgo basic needs in pursuit
of their art form the SCP 376a enters
its tertiary stage approximately 13
months after initial exposure subjects
will begin to produce anomalous artwork
most commonly bearing Cognito hazardous
material it is unconfirmed whether the
SCP 376a is able to spread via these
Works addendum 3076 1 recovery SC CP 376
was found after incident
30665 in the forests of lynville gorge
North Carolina it was initially
collected by Foundation operatives as
part of the Reconstruction operation
after incident
3665 and its anomalous properties
discovered after many of the Personnel
involved with its recovery began to
neglect their professional duties upon
confirmation of its anomalous properties
SCP 376 was moved to site 104 for
containment and further study addendum
3076 2 sample test log the following is
an incomplete log of SCP 376 testing to
highlight noteworthy findings test five
subject
d469 note before incarceration d469 was
a mural
artist description d469 was made to
spend two full days in the presence of
CP 376 before being removed from the
containment chamber even before removal
d469 repeatedly requested access to
painting materials and began using the
foliage within the containment chamber
as a pigment to paint the walls it is
worth note that SCP 376 attempted to Aid
d469 in her work on several
occasions upon removal the subject was
provided with an intervenous hydration
and parental nut nutrition to ensure
survival then provided with the
requested materials against
administrative recommendation d469 was
allowed to work on the walls of site 104
facilities and covered 74% of the
accessible surfaces on site with murals
of varying subject matter 103 days after
initial exposure d469 produced a Cognito
hazardous piece covering one of the
exterior walls of the main research
complex the VI of the piece would cause
rapid memory loss and demential like
symptoms though d469 herself was immune
to the effect the test subject was
immediately terminated and all
contaminated surfaces destroyed this has
been an extremely expensive misjudgment
on the part of research staff I'll see
to it that those responsible are held
accountable site
director test s subject a non-anomalous
African bush elephant loxodon Africana
description the subject was made to
spend two full days in the presence of
SCP 376 before being removed from
containment chamber 23 hours after
removal the subject became agitated and
paced around its holding pen before
using its drinking water to produce
seemingly random Splash patterns on the
ground the subject was provided with
simple painting materials and began
teaching itself how to use them 40 days
after initial exposure the subject was
consistently producing recognizable
images of elephants and had stopped
actively seeking food a modified
intervenous nutritional system was
provided and testing continued 57 days
later the subject was able to produce
photorealistic representations of its
surroundings 120 days after initial
exposure test supervisors reported
unusual headaches and nose bleeds while
observing the subject in the process of
painting the test object was
preemptively terminated and all
accumulated Works
incinerated test 10 subject SCP
3076 description SCP 3076 was placed in
a containment chamber fitted with wall
spanning mirrors 7 days were allowed to
pass no changes in the behavior of SCP
376 were noted Beyond some curiosity in
its own reflection SCP 3076 became
Restless after 6 days and fainted
illness causing the unscheduled
termination of the
test test 13 subject a standard
foundation desktop computer description
the subject was placed in the same
chamber as SCP 376 provided with a
dedicated power supply and disconnected
from the foundation internet a camera
and evolutionary symphonic generation
software were installed the software was
made to produce new music as quickly as
it could and would use direct input from
test supervisors to judge the quality of
the generated
compositions after 5 days the subject
ran out of RAM and the software became
ineffective necessary modifications were
made and the test continued 23 days
after initial exposure the subject began
producing variations on the same two
compositions believing that the program
had exhausted its selection of media a
flash drive of new sound elements was
supplied as as well as further
improvements to the hardware the test
subject continued to underperform
despite the
modifications 24 days after initial
exposure an unknown virus was found
within the site 104 computer system
while Foundation Personnel attempted to
remove the threat all speakers on site
were used to produce a Cognito hazardous
sound simultaneously the malicious
program hijacked on-site Communications
and began transmitting itself to all
Foundation sites site 104 was
quarantined and its power cut off in
time to prevent catastrophic damage
though widespread injury to on-site
Personnel due to the sound was sustained
during Reconstruction it was discovered
that SCP 376 had made several attempts
to physically tamper with the test
subject It is believed that SCP 376 was
attempting to connect the device to the
foundation internet during quarantine
but was
unsuccessful we might have to run a few
more tests on the intelligence of this
bird for the time being it seems smart
to keep computers away from it we don't
want a Rog gay eye on our hands site
[Music]
director okay I think that about does it
for today thank you for listening if
indeed you still are and you all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran jack wall o krap guy James
Saba Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire cubster Dean
Dingus Mr D Chuck oscuro Vision Grim
near extra moments 1
23 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you
[Music]